i'm so curious if it's because
you know i don't know do we come in with
a mission is there something that we're
meant to do and so there's an innate
knowing or is it because i decided to
believe in it that it happened what do
you think i think it can be a combo
platter danica i think in my my case and
it sounds like your case there was
nothing i wanted to do more than be an
actor
a singer and dancer there was nothing
i would have i lived with four roommates
in bunk beds with a clapper okay i did
whatever i had to do to make it there
are certain kids that aren't gonna want
to do that and i understand they won't
have a normal life they want to be able
to plan on a paycheck you know well they
want medical you know they want all
these things yeah i was at vacation
bible school one year and
god literally said you're gonna be a
missionary and i was like oh not me you
got the wrong
four seasons hotel remember me god
anyway um
the missionary turns out to be
of a different it didn't look like what
i thought it was going to look like okay
describe the missionary what it what how
how what is it
let's go to indonesia let's feed the
poor really feed the poor and sick that
we're supposed to do like let's go on a
journey let's spread the word of what
works for us makes us happy
being able to do that and i didn't think
it would be
talking about god or the lord or jesus
on broadway or maybe on a talk show or
maybe here today with you or i didn't
even think when i grew up that it was
all that
different
until i got to new york and i found out
that i was different
[Music]
and i liked it i got the lesson early in
life too where
being different
once i finally allowed that because
there was a time that i kind of resisted
it where i didn't want to wear nail
polish heels like look too girly because
i mean i'm using my hands to describe
the car and i really need to reinforce
what's really obvious
um but as soon as i allowed myself to be
a woman in in different ways and and
just kind of go there it was like
through some photo shoots and stuff i
was like wow this doesn't actually take
away from anything that i'm doing it
makes me special and this is what's
unique and different about me and this
is like this is a cultural thing and and
and that people want to be like someone
else look like someone else do what
someone else does and and the truth of
it is is that they can never like
they'll they will literally never be the
person that they think is so great that
they want to be like um it's not
possible and the only thing you can do
is be second best and that's not gonna
get you there that's not gonna set it's
not gonna blaze a trail and so
the best thing you can do is figure out
what it is that's actually different
about you and run with it
i could not agree with you more that's
what i tell my kids all the time you're
saying it i wish they were all listening
you young broadway boot campers if
you're listening to this danica just
said what i say all the time man if you
if you can take that ball to the end
game and love it
like nobody gets input and if you can do
it with a weird run
do it you know do it i'm 411.
i have this unique speaking voice
you know i'm sure that in at times in my
career it has not served me but mostly
it has served me well because it's made
me different
and i've accepted that i sound like
betty boop and i've accepted that i
can't see over most counters and i've
accepted the things about me that were
made fun of and that we fit better in
japan that's all there is to it when we
go please i love japan uh did you ever
resist it like did you have a point in
time where you resisted it that you you
know and what was that like because i
feel as though
you know
you know i'm all about trying harder and
pushing and there's definitely some of
that needed in life you've got to be
able to push through things to some
degree when it's difficult not
everything is so great but it's like
trying to recognize when you need to
pivot
and turn away from something go a
different direction let something go
and were there times where that you kind
of had to sort of get beat over the head
a little bit to get the message or not
when you cannot get a lesson and you're
so busy and you cannot hear the lesson
you cannot see the lesson that's what
sometimes it literally doesn't land on
your head and i was on it on a set with
a good wife doing maybe six episodes of
it and my day two the set big old set
piece thing landed on my head
fell in on my head and i was out of work
for six months what and i said yeah i
say this story because i had i had a
brain concussion and a six inch
cut and nose neck and ribs so what what
was hard for me was not to lay there
because on broadway we just get up and
we go
but with you know you broke out a broken
leg you wrap it up and you get that back
out there go but with a head injury
um i was in the middle of touring and
stuff
they were not they weren't gonna let me
do that so i had that that and i call it
my own personal hell
of healing of being quiet
and listening when i
go go go go and i was like what's the
lesson what's the lesson what's the
lesson god's like i keep trying to tell
you like you've fallen in a hole which i
have backwards hurt your head another
another time like a light thing fell off
on me in the wing he's like i'm trying
to get your attention person because i
want you to rest
so that you can continue to do what you
love because i'm so used to working
through pain and injury i'm sorry but
that's a fact or sickness or tire you
know that's just what we do
and he just like stop
stop and smell the roses similarly i
remember it was a few years back
and i was like pushing hard i mean i was
still racing i was in nascar and
i was working out all the time working
out two a days you know i was killing it
and i mean i probably kind of knew that
i was pushing a little too hard within a
month i
spray my ankle and i even thought this
is a sign but i was like i'll just do
you know some upper body stuff and then
i was like
you know so doing that and then a couple
weeks later i'm doing a handstand in my
living room and i fell out of it a
little bit and when i landed my finger
went down and went
straight
i mean it's still bigger than this one
right here is still bigger than the
other one it's still it's been like four
years
and i so then now i have a sprained
finger and or like torn ligaments is
really good i'd rather have this sprain
than torn ligament oh yeah so it was
torn ligaments my ankle torn ligaments
in my finger and i'm like
finally the body was like i'm like okay
i get it no more time
like well i was thinking when you're
talking about this story i'm thinking
about um our gymnast yeah simone who
just had
so everybody was talking i was um
just walking off stage like my second
show back was feeling really good and
happy and i wanted to know how it went
for her
and my mom called me and she said the
most beautiful thing happened with her
i said she won everything she beat her
own time blah blah blah blah she said no
none of that
i have vertigo i have an inner ear
problem and so i'm very conscious when
someone can't land something or they
seem off i'm very aware that because she
said i'm spinning she kept saying i'm
spinning and i can't land i don't know
what she has and i'm not
i have no idea but what she did
in a matter of a few hours
by showing her team and the world what
kind of sports woman she is to me was
more important than anything she could
have beat or won her time so her lesson
was actually a lesson for us
to watch someone with such grace
say i can't do it i can't do it but my
team can and i'm going to be there for
him and that's that's probably why i
like doing broadway and
why i like a fam
familial feel
um
i imagine in your sport it's fun but it
could be maybe a little lonely i think
that about track stars you know you're
only competing with yourself well yeah i
am too because if they want me for a
part they certainly don't want someone
else if they want someone else they
certainly don't want me but what i have
learned is like really chris life's
short
life is so short and the sweating the
small stuff is just
not worth it